All right. So I created a new class called RecordedAudio with two fields,
filePathUrl and title.
The next thing I will do is go back to RecordSoundsViewController and
then scroll to this audioRecorderDidFinishRecording function.
The first thing I have to do here is I have to save the recorded audio, and
I will do that with the most recent class I have created.
So what I will do is scroll up to the very top and
then create a new object for this class which is RecordedAudio.
There. And then I'll scroll back to my function, and
in here I will initialize the new object.
There.
Now I can set the attributes of this object.
One of them is filePathURL.
The value for this can be obtained using the recorder parameter.
This is the reference to the audio file that was actually recorded on the phone.
So I can say something like recorder.url.
Then I will set the title of this object recordedAudio.
I can get this value from the recorder parameter also.
I can say recorder.url.lastPathComponent, this gives
us the name of the recorded file.
All right, with that, step one is done.
Step two is to perform a segue to the next scene.
I can accomplish that by calling the performSegueWithIdentifier function.
You should not that we inherit this method from UIViewController.
Now, Xcode is asking me for an identifier of the segue, and
I recall that the idea of my segue was stopRecording there.
Just as a quick recap, however, let me go back to my storyboard and then select
this segue and slide the utility tray out to see that the identifier for
this segue was in fact stopRecording.
Okay, let me go back to my code.
Now, for this second parameter,
sender, we will pass in the new object, recordedAudio.
Let me do that.
This is the object that actually initiates the segue.
All right, so it seems like step two is also done.
By the way, at this point I want to highlight that the name of our function is
called audioRecorderDidFinishRecording successfully.
And the way we can figure out if the recording was in fact
accomplished successfully is by using this boolean flag.
So I will add an if statement here.
And enclose all of this code within that if statement.
If for some reason the audio recording does not finish successfully,
then what I can do is print out an error message and
update the correct settings on my buttons.
All right.
Let's run our project.
Okay, let me record something.
Is this going to work?
Okay, so
it seems that the segue is happening, and this time it's happening through code.
And now let me play the sound.
>> My mom always said life was like a box of chocolates.
>> Hm, the app is still playing the movie quote.
Why do you think our app is still playing the quote and not the recorded voice?
Enter your thoughts in this box.